[Music]
in love is complicated news Snow's not
it's so easy
hmm submitted by all my single lads I'm
a single let's no redditors discuss
whether or not it's okay to be unsure if
your partner is the one who discuss this
redditors reading on reddit Oh redditors
predators right I think if you have to
discuss it anyway good read the article
no go go go - what we're gonna say no I
want her to go first okay fine
really this is really easy I think if
you're questioning if this person's the
one then they're not the one oh I guess
I better [ __ ] run then cuz I
questioned it a lot but yours is
different it's not black and white like
that I don't think everyone's the same I
feel like if you found it and you're
like it's [ __ ] it like alright that's
cool and then sometimes people don't
figure that out - we've thought that in
the beginning that you were the one like
five years later that sometimes changes
but then yeah it's just because when I
you know well your reasons for the one
is gonna determine if that person yeah I
guess yeah and also passion doesn't live
forever so a lot of times is true theme
yeah for that person to be the one I
hope that's not true it's been studied
but there's exceptions to a role and
hopefully your unexceptional yeah
because like every other relationship I
would have agreed with you cuz I'm like
yeah I wasn't wrong for five years and
in the beginning the first three years
were like [ __ ] amazing and then like
the last two years I was like oh I don't
feel anything
and I was like me maybe love dies maybe
like Pasteur discovered but now it's
been six years in this relationship and
it's more hot than ever yeah which is
awesome and so like what I've learned
and the research then I'd [ __ ] love
all these things the honeymoon stage it
comes back so like it'll die down and
then it'll come back and then it'll go
like through the same cycle and then
I'll come back you know I think it is
for me at least and I can't speak for
everybody and I can't speak to
statistics or whatever but he's the
first guy that hasn't hurt me alright
and so yeah and so every other
relationship was really really hurtful
in the beginning there was a lot of like
lying there's a lot of trust issues
there were things that like try trade my
love
and and I think with Steve everything
has only built it and raised it and so
you this both of you guys with each
other are very vulnerable and open and
yes communicate which is cute that is
it is huge I didn't realized how big of
a difference that makes but he will tell
you it's because he never shits in front
of me or like lets me hear or farts he
never farts he never you never fart he
never farts no and he's very adamant
about me never smelling or hearing him
[ __ ] that's good though yeah what how do
you guys do were you all like hotel
trips well a lot of times like I wake up
first like I'll wake up at like 6:00 in
the morning and he wakes up at like
10:00 in the morning so like I get my
stuff done there and then I go yeah I
basically I go exercise and stuff and
that's when he's doing his stuff nice
yeah I like that guy's make it work
so yeah this question was posted on
reddit it said is it okay to not know if
he's the one and so like the most up
voted one or like the top that's why it
says that since a little bit long it
says um so they were playing to this
thing that says I hear so many married
couples saying I knew my wife was the
one the day I met her so the reply says
yeah they're full of [ __ ] I love my wife
the thought of being without her now
makes me feel like I'm standing on the
edge of a cliff with the with the wind
pushing hard at my back if something
happened to her I'd have to learn how to
breathe all over again she's in me so
deep I'm not sure how my heart would
ever be tweaked I wrote this she makes
me so happy I don't have words for it
I remember the first time I saw her I
remembered her name but that was it she
introduced herself to a room full of
people we didn't talk until days later
we became friends not long after that
within months I really liked her but it
was much longer before it became love
really actually love and much longer
still before I was sure that I loved her
forever it's completely okay to not know
that there to not know that they're the
one completely the thing people feel at
first wait the thing people feel at
first sight is at most lust or
infatuation it can lead to love love can
start there but it can just as easily
end up
at incompatibility or toxicity a
functional relationship doesn't just
happen you have to communicate you have
to learn to understand each other know
the things the other person needs to
feel loved and cared for know what they
cared just as much about you feeling
loved and care for you need to learn how
to resolve it when you disagree love
happens slowly it grows on you like a
fungus wrote it and then the end I'm
like oh no imagine it was a girl and she
was like oh I have to make this gross
fungus I think maybe people think that
when you think like a love is no doubt
they they maybe think love is no fight
love agreement yeah love is not easy
it's not no and it's a lot of
disagreements and it's a lot of doubt of
like oh my god are you dumb but never
like is he the one you know like like
most times does not I see the one most
times it's like oh my god like I have to
deal with it you know but you learn to
communicate and like said those
boundaries and you learn to like have a
middle ground for the both of you I
think answers are in the problems how
you problem-solve
is the answer if that person is the one
because you're gonna problems no matter
what can you solve them in a way that
like builds your relationship even
before that is are they the one to
enough to want to solve those problems
yeah so um I think I think if you're
asking are the other one then look at
all the bad [ __ ] and just be like well
do I want to work to [ __ ] out with them
work it out with me if you if you're
still want to work through out through
it in the batter that's when you know
you know like if in the batter you're
like oh my god like it's so annoying or
it's so painful right so whatever but I
still need to talk to you and like
listen to you and whatever and if you
still want to then that means they're
worth it for you you know I think
commitment wise if you're gonna get
married to somebody and then you're
doubting if they're the one they might
not be the one yeah like if you're
thinking like what I want to marry this
person do I want to marry this person
it's kind of like you should want to
marry the person and not doubt like
that's the litmus test when you think
about like a whole life with them yeah
like if you can consider if you can't
for like
be sure that you want your whole life
spent with that person then they're
probably like you're probably wasting
your time these people are talking about
like the people that are like I knew
they were the one from the minute I saw
and it's like yeah you need like some
time to figure out how you guys work
together operate together but
communicate with each other I think is a
question it's just like it's five years
long your patience runs that's true and
I think like for example the first time
I met my boyfriend I was like oh man
this feels special like it doesn't feel
like all the other times it felt a
little bit more special and then as we
got to know each other it was like
alright this is why it was special and
like you still haven't done anything so
[ __ ] up that I can deal with you know
what I mean but if ever comes a time I'm
like alright this was not the one you
know because I'm sure there's gonna be
others that will be special too but then
it's just a matter of seeing if it'll
work out and what you're willing to
compromise and it's really Trish it cuz
like with Casey too like I felt that the
moment we met oh there's something there
that I haven't never felt any one before
and then like it was it's just been
great but it's been a [ __ ] roller
coaster and insane timing cover us yeah
sure I'm like discovering how we both
deal with our own problems and not like
literally just now we figured [ __ ] out
we're we're like okay so this is the way
you communicate through the way I come
you know this is how we can love each
other this is how you want to be loved
this is how I want to be left in all
these met what six years in seven oh
seven years seven years it took us to
really figure it out but like this whole
time though we've all we both really
loved each other we both really wanted
to work out that we weren't
communicating the same way yeah so it's
just it's it that's why I'm a firm
believer of like you create your love
and like you have to work at your love
yeah yeah understanding but
understanding I go back to them saying
like when you know it's the one you know
what I mean like like we've all kind of
like the same thing with Bart like when
I first met him like in a romantic
setting then I was like oh [ __ ] like
this connection is wild and it wasn't
like anything I had ever felt with
anyone else and for me I guess at that
point I wouldn't have to question if
he's the one
you know now it's like building the
relationship and making sure we're
communicating and loving each other's
making sure it's stable but for example
do you feel like he's the only one like
if like you know like god forbid but if
something was to happen and you were
forced to be out in the dating world
again I don't I don't feel like that's
realistic though to be like he's the
only one right so there will be another
ones I've had connections with females
not in a romantic way at all but like
I've had like with my best friend where
I felt the exact same connection I'm
like oh [ __ ] like damn like I feel like
I've known this person you know so if I
can have that within a platonic sense
and I feel like I can have that again
with another thing that I miss leading
part where people get really sucked into
it is the fact that it's called like the
one like there's only one yeah like I
also don't believe that there's just one
person out there for everyone it's the
one you choose to work it out with your
life yeah I think it's like the one
after all the other ones like not like
the one like in the whole like the main
ones like the ones that happen that one
that's way better than all the other one
that stuck yeah yeah exactly so another
response here on reddit said like even
if you know on day one you might not not
know on day 500 we knew a day one we
were like yeah yeah yeah so they're just
saying like you know nobody's path is so
linear and simple they just a single day
knowing that this is one-of-a-kind
perfect bliss that's so unrealistic not
happily ever after and you're not really
disappointed when you're having doubts
you'll be like all [ __ ] like is this
like you'll you'll punish yourself more
mentally than you have to if you put
that kind of pressure on yourself you
know it's normal to feel I just watched
the video YouTube that was talking about
like it's normal to have fight it's
normal to get bored it's normal to not
feel that passionate love all the time
especially throughout the years but then
that's when it's a like it'll go back to
the moon a honeymoon face eventually if
you work on it yeah that's totally
working right now that's we all like
finally figure it out everything we feel
like wearing our new like honeymoon
stage we're a thing what I think this is
who you've been this whole time and I
just we didn't know I can you see the
that way didn't see each other and I was
just really happy with me and Steve
after the first year because we saw each
other as like completely different
people like everything was great there
was that connection right off the bat
and I was like whoa he's the one then
like after moving in and like living
with each other for a little bit there
were certain things where I was reading
it as cocky or arrogant or whatever like
I was reading him a certain way of his
intentions where I was reading him a
certain way and he did the same thing to
me where he was reading me a certain way
he thought the same thing about me and
then like we it came to a head right
we're like we were really gonna break up
like he tried to break up with me and
then I threw a table and then he's like
he was like kazoos that passion you know
and he's never like felt that from any
other person that I and then he and I
ran to the bathroom and I was like
crying I was like basically putting up
walls and stuff and he was like I will
never ever ever leave you I'll never do
that and then that's when we like pulled
the oh yeah we do it we call it pulling
the arrows out but we said things so
effective guys yeah it was just things
that we both had been weighing heavy
weighing subconscious and missiles up
and you don't even realize it's in your
body and so every time you like every
little thing that person does you can
read it as like they're just again yeah
it's just because this built up [ __ ] and
so you we addressed one by one from the
beginning of our relationship all the
things that we were carrying and holding
on to and we released them and we've
never brought those problems up ever
again because I see him who for who he
really is and vice versa and I think
that was like 100% the rebirth of our
and it was work it was work it's not
like you were like it was perfect though
it was work and now you're like we're
here because we did that work yeah but
that's why I think that every year has
been better than the last because it's
like that first year was the hardest
year where most people that first year's
the honeymoon year yeah it was not a
honeymoon year for us yeah
[Music]